espagne des expulsions quotidiennes ont
lieu alors que des milliers de locaux
appartenant à des particuliers et à des
gros propriétaires fonciers sont vides
un cocktail idéal pour l'explosion du
phénomène qui est l'occupation illégale
des logements
[Applaudissements]
les chiffres sont éloquents plus de 14
mille plaintes ont été déposées en 2020
pour occupation illégale de propriété
privée justice sociale pour les uns abus
intolérables pour d'autres et pour la
majorité une solution improvisé qui ne
satisfait personne à part peut-être les
sociétés de sécurité et celles qui
s'occupent de l'expulsion des résidents
le correspondant de rtl francesco
brescia est allé à la rencontre de ceux
que ce problème a touché directement
afin d'appréhender toutes les facettes
de ce phénomène bien plus complexe qu'on
pourrait le croire de prime abord
[Musique]
je
il ya quelques semaines à peine personne
entrer dans ce bâtiment complètement
vide cet immeuble résidentiel est resté
à moitié inachevé pendant la crise de la
bulle immobilière de 2008
maintenant il ya du mouvement dans
chaque appartement des câbles
électriques sont installés et des
carrelages sont posés dans les salles de
bain et en quelques heures seulement ce
bâtiment est passé de vide à occuper
notre objectif est de résoudre le
problème du logement pour des familles
dans le besoin qui ne peuvent pas
obtenir 1 3 par d'autres moyens le squat
est le dernier recours après de
nombreuses tentatives infructueuses
d'obtenir un logement décent
quatorze mille plants ont été déposées
en espagne en 2020 contre l'occupation
de logements selon un rapport du
département de la protection sociale de
barcelone 80 % de la propriété squatter
appartient à des fonds d'investissement
et à de grands propriétaires fonciers
par exemple ce bâtiment est propriété de
l'entreprise ça reb qui s'occupe des
biens immobiliers les plus
problématiques de banque sauvée de la
banqueroute
des milliers de logements vides comme
celui ci peuvent être trouvées partout
dans le pays à ce bâtiment était vide
depuis plus de 13 ans désormais au moins
huit familles en situation de précarité
vivront ici
malgré leurs difficultés financières
juan pedro et raquel ont toujours refusé
d'occuper un logement vide les eaux
chercher d'autres solutions pour obtenir
un toit pourtant il ya quelques mois ils
ont été expulsés de leur appartement en
location pour impayés
l'administration locale n'ayant pas
réglé leurs problèmes ils ont frappé à
la porte des organisations dette sociale
amo
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir un logement
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux il y
en a toujours plus
tout cela à cause d'une mauvaise gestion
des banques afin d'abriter les fonds
vautours et de la spéculation
ce n'est pas la première fois que juan
pedro et raquel font face à ce problème
ils ont été expulsés trois fois de leur
logement ils ont dû passer des nuits
dans leur voiture ou dans des centres
d'accueil ces quinze dernières années la
précarité le chômage les accompagnent
ils ont pour la première fois et
expulser de leur appartement en 2008 ils
ont non seulement perdu leur toit mais
où les a également privé de la tutelle
de leurs enfants la généralité de
catalogne nous apprennent aux enfants
parce qu'on nous expulsé de
l'appartement les enfants se seraient
retrouvées sans abri nous avons demandé
de l'aide aux assistants sociaux mais au
lieu de nous aider ils nous ont juste
pris nos enfants
chaque occupations de bâtiments de ce
genre est précédé de négociations avec
la mairie et de conversations avec les
voisins on leur explique la situation et
il faut un plan secret pour ne pas être
expulsé lorsque la police tentera de
récupérer le logement occupé en plus il
faudra faire face à des démêlés avec la
loi un procès peut durer des mois voire
des années
au même moment un processus inverse a
lieu ailleurs en espagne
l'expulsion de résidents illégaux ou aux
coûts passent d'un immeuble
plusieurs familles squatte depuis
quelques mois des appartements vides
dans le centre de madrid
[Musique]
ici pas de police ni de commission
judiciaire une société de sécurité
privée s'en chargent rails mais a créé
son entreprise il ya cinq ans en face à
l'explosion du nombre de cas et pour
pallier l'absence de réaction des
pouvoirs publics
je pense que les juges sont submergés
par le nombre de cas la loi fonctionne
mais à présent elle n'est pas efficace
parce que les tribunaux sont débordés
par tous ces dossiers
depuis quelques semaines déjà rhymes et
ses collègues cherche à expulser des
squatteurs de ce bâtiment le plus
difficile est déjà passé 11 ans au cou
passe sur 14 ont déjà quitté les lieux
on peut parler
il frappe de façon répétée aux portes
des appartements où se trouve encore des
squatters l'un d'eux s'appelle gabriel
il vient de se réveiller tu as dix
minutes pour tablier et après on va
discuter ok peu après ramener ses
collègues reviennent à la charge on
pourrait d'abord croire que gabriel a
l'intention de rester ici quelques jours
de plus jusqu'au 30 on est 24
aujourd'hui
n'ont pourtant l'expression de son
visage changeant quelques secondes il
est prêt à quitter l'appartement
l'essentiel du travail de rails mais
consiste à persuader la personne de
quitter le logement dans les meilleurs
délais
j'appelle ça du taekwondo verbal ma
tâche est de discuter et d'aidé en fin
de compte si la personne a besoin d aide
il faut les aider bien sûr je pense que
si tu est hostile et que tu entres comme
un missile qui obtiendra le même type de
réponse on
a besoin pour le moment de passer à des
mesures plus musclées comme des
contrôles ou des chiens à l'entrée
l'entreprise expulsion légal s'en tient
à une procédure éprouver les
spécialistes entre dans l'appartement
vérifier son état et demande à gabriel
de confirmer par écrit qu'ils quittent
l'appartement de son propre gré demain
il reviendra dans l'appartement pour
chercher ses affaires laissées sur place
je vais le refaire oui si je n'ai pas
d'endroit où vivre je trouverais tout
simplement un autre appartement à
squatter
rails mais n'a pas perdu de temps et a
commencé à négocier avec un autre
résident il n'en reste plus que deux
dans le bâtiment selon rails mais si
beaucoup profitent sans scrupules de la
lenteur de la loi certains cas s'avère
bien plus compliqué
nous travaillons en ce moment sur un car
la propriétaire est atteinte d'une
leucémie elle comprend qu'elle va
bientôt mourir mais les occupants
refusent de quitter les lieux elle veut
tout réglé par avance pour que ses
enfants n'est pas de soucis après
pour beaucoup de propriétaires ces
entreprises de sécurité sont le moyen le
plus rapide de chasser des squatteurs de
leur appartement
cela permet de contourner le problème de
l'engorgement du système judiciaire et
de lutter contre l'impunité dont
jouissent un certain nombre
d'organisations
pourtant certains citoyens considère
l'entreprise qui s'occupe des expulsions
comme une bande de malfrats qui
profitent du vide juridique et agissent
en marge de la loi plus d'une vingtaine
de plaintes ont été déposées contre
rails mais pour coercition et menace il
dit n'avoir jamais perdu devant les
tribunaux
l'ambiance est tendue c'est clair il
peut comprendre pourquoi ils peuvent
penser que nous sommes des bandits bien
sûr ils ont droit de le croire il faut
penser aussi à ceux qui sont dans les
bâtiments et à ce qui nous attend à
l'intérieur mais je ne contraint et
n'humilie jamais personne
à la spa quelques jours plus tard rails
mais elle a réussi à libérer le bâtiment
les traces des squatters sont toujours
là le propriétaire a atteint son
objectif et le bâtiment est de nouveau
sous son contrôle la tâche de rallier
est terminée et il a reçu la somme
convenue et voici ce qu'il répond quand
on lui demande comment résoudre le
problème structurel de l'immobilier en
espagne
bien sûr je comprends qu'il ya une
pénurie de logement social en espagne
à l'espagne est le pays de l'ue eux qui
possède le moins de logements sociaux
seulement une résidence sociale pour
cent personnes c'est quatre fois moins
que la moyenne de l'union européenne
[Musique]
là ce sont les jeunes qui en souffrent
le plus l'immense majorité des jeunes de
moins de 30 ans ne peuvent pas se
permettre d'acheter ou de louer seule en
appartement dans aucune région du pays
un autre problème pour accéder au
logement et la spéculation immobilière
selon le site photo casa les loyers ont
augmenté de 40% en espagne ces cinq
dernières années en outre des millions
de citoyens font face à de graves
difficultés financières
un habitant du pays sur cinq est sous le
seuil de pauvreté
d'ailleurs tous ne sont pas au chômage
l'espagne est le deuxième pays de
l'union européenne comptant le plus de
travailleurs pauvres
[Musique]
cet endroit est un refuge émotionnelle
pour des dizaines de résidants du
quartier de noob harris à barcelone
ville où les expulsions sont les plus
fréquentes mais aussi où les squats sont
les plus nombreux on vient ici pour
échanger sur les problèmes de logement
et essayer de trouver une solution
chaque histoire un visage humain tout
est basé sur la participation
les syndicats d'habitants du quartier se
réunissent ici une fois par semaine
ces réunions nous donne une raison de me
lever de mon lit de sortir de chez moi
de lutter pour mes droits rien qui ne
figure pas dans la constitution
raquel est naturellement devenu l'une
des figures de proue de cette
organisation depuis 15 ans l'instabilité
fait partie de son quotidien elle a
squatté trois fois et a été expulsé à
deux reprises
avant j'étais une femme d'affaires
j'étais propriétaire
j'avais mes propres sociétés
mais le destin a fait qu'à un moment
donné j'ai tout perdu et j'ai dû squatté
avant j'avais postulé pour un crédit
hypothécaire préférentiel en tant
qu'handicapé
mais ça m'a été refusé
on
[Musique]
vous n'entendrez pas d'histoires simples
lors de cette réunion aujourd'hui un
nouveau membre du syndicat est venu
raconter son cas demain l'expulsion d'un
immeuble où résident illégalement quatre
familles précaires sera ordonnée elle
demande à l'assemblée d'empêcher le
lancement de cette procédure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant la pandémie soixante mille
expulsions en moyenne avaient lieu
chaque année c'est la crise économique
déclenchée par le cos vide a donné le
feu vert à l'adoption d'une loi sur la
lutte contre l'expulsion des familles
précaires si le rythme de ces expulsions
à diminuer elles ont toujours lieu la
majorité d'entre elles se déroulent en
toute discrétion des drames humains
quasiment oublié
le profil des squatteurs le plus
nombreux et qui augmente le plus vite ce
sont les mères-célibataires
surtout les mères racialisée avec des
enfants à charge
pas forcément des personnes jeunes ou
qui ne veulent pas travailler
un vingtaine d'expulsion ont lieu chaque
jour en catalogne ces familles occuper
ce local vide depuis longtemps la
commission judiciaire et la police sont
venus pour les expulser
c'est là pourtant un groupe de militants
essaient de les en empêcher la police
régionale de catalogne n'est pas en
nombre suffisant pour mener à bien
l'opération
les agents ont besoin de renfort le
suspense est à son comble et la tension
monte
une personne est expulsé elle plonge
dans un état d'anxiété de stress elle se
sent abandonnés par les pouvoirs publics
les organisations de voisins par tout le
monde elle se retrouve littéralement en
situation de survie
quelques minutes plus tard les policiers
confirment qu'il n'y aura pas de
renforts il est impossible de procéder à
l'expulsion la police s'en va les
résidents et les militants ne cachent
pas leur joie
[Applaudissements]
la raison principale de l'échec de
l'expulsion et que les forces de l'ordre
manque de personnel
voilà pourquoi les organisations de
protection des droits de l'homme et
c'est d'inviter le plus de monde
possible à des actions comme celle ci
[Applaudissements]
la catalogne est la région d'espagne où
a lieu le plus grand nombre d'expulsions
elles représentent 22 % de tous les cas
recensés dans le pays
dans le même temps c'est la communauté
autonome où le nombre d'appartements
occupés est le plus élevé le fardeau est
donc très lourd la moitié de toutes les
plaintes contre les occupants du pays
sont déposés en catalogne ici il y a six
fois plus de maisons squattées que dans
la communauté de madrid
ce qui est le plus alarmant ce n'est
même plus le nombre en soi mais le fait
que le propriétaire sont impuissants
face aux occupe à ce qu'ils s'emparent
de leur logement et refuse de les
quitter
l'expulsion traîne souvent en longueur
et pour beaucoup de propriétaires
l'argent que rapporte leur logement est
vital pour subsister
[Musique]
il est né à une nouvelle réunion avec
son avocate elle ne peut pas pénétrer
dans son appartement depuis déjà
quatorze ans à la louer son appartement
à une femme en 2008 celle ci a payé
pendant trois mois et à cesser de verser
son loyer par la suite
le plus frustrant c'est l'impuissance
nous ne pouvons rien faire
est ce que le système judiciaire ne
réagit pas
nous sommes
un étranger peut faire ce qu'il veut
dans son appartement et tu as absolument
impuissant je ne peux pas te défendre
je crois qu'aujourd'hui la loi protège
les au cou parce la législation non
seulement les protège mais les aides
elles les couvre
au mirinae avait conclu un contrat de
location la locataire n'est pas une
squatteuse elle est simplement considéré
comme quelqu'un qui violent les
conditions du contrat si irene c'est
d'entrer dans son propre appartement
elle peut être accusé de violation de
domicile elle se demande comment une
telle situation est possible
le propriétaire victimes de l'occupation
de sa propriété est obligée de subir le
fait que le plus souvent on vandalisme
sont bien mais en plus il ne peut pas
louer son logement et tout le voisinage
se révoltent contre lui
et l'envié pendant que l'allocataire
jouit gratuitement de l'appartement
dirait d elle-même a toutefois fait
l'objet d'une procédure d'expulsion
irene dans une situation financière
difficile elle est au chômage et perçoit
une allocation de 400 euros en raison
d'une grave maladie dégénérative
aujourd'hui elle bénéficie d'un logement
social
cela m'a beaucoup affecté du point de
vue émotionnel je suis dévasté épuisé
il aimait à conduire est né à embaucher
plusieurs avocats elle a essayé de
négocier avec sa locataire elle a alerté
les médias et décrit la situation sur
les réseaux sociaux elle a également
envisagé d'appeler un service spécial
d'expulsion la justice travaille si
lentement que même les avocats
conseillent de prendre un raccourci est
de s'adresser à une entreprise de
sécurité
en fait c'est un mécanisme plus souple
et plus rapide si le propriétaire un
prêt à négocier avec les occupants à
leur payer une certaine somme pour qu'il
quitte son appartement un évitant que
l'affairé soit portée devant les
tribunaux qui décideront d'expulser la
personne dans les rues
car là c'est mal c'est une tradition
chaque semaine irene sonne à la porte de
son appartement pour rappeler à sa
locataire qu'elle occupe un logement qui
ne lui appartient pas quand elle ne
répond pas irene appel sur son portable
comme souvent la femme dit qu'elle va
bientôt déménager
georgina oui quand est-ce que tu des
ménages demain est séparé de cette fois
c'est bel et bien le cas la femme a
déménagé irene tient dans sa main les
clés de son appartement où elle entre
pour la première fois depuis 14 ans
tout est vide l'ancien locataire a
emporté avec elle les meubles et
l'électroménager qui ne lui appartient
pas maintenant irene devra dépenser
plusieurs milliers d'euros
[Musique]
le gouvernement espagnol a adopté en
2008 une loi d' expulsion rapide afin
d'accélérer le processus
en outre la loi a été amendée afin
d'alourdir les peines de prison pour les
coupables mais ces mesures n'ont pas
résolu le problème
l'impunité l'absence de solution et la
précarité de millions de personnes
constituant terreau pour l'émergence
d'organisations criminelles qui
cherchent à s'enrichir
elle trouve un immeuble vide et s'y
installent illégalement pour ensuite le
sous louer ou vendre les clés à des
familles précaires pour 1000 ou 2000
euros
ce n'est qu'une des facettes de
l'occupation de logements et repère de
dealers sont probablement la
manifestation la plus dangereuse de ce
phénomène les habitants du quartier
raval à barcelone connaissent bien le
problème des dizaines d'appartements
vides se sont transformés en points de
deal et de prostitution il s'agit
d'appartements dont les occupants ont
été expulsés et de locaux inutilisés qui
se sont transformés en repaire de
délinquants un jour mon fils a vu un
homme qui faisait une overdose et m'a
demandé il se sent mal j'ai répondu oui
il ne se sent pas bien alors mon fils a
répondu normale sur ce pic n'a que trois
ans
face à l'inaction des autorités la roja
a décidé d'aller plus loin et de se
lancer dans la politique elle discute
avec des résidents qui lui font part de
leurs préoccupations et dans l'un des
nombreux logements sociaux se trouvent
en repaire de dealers
vous voyez cette horreur
[Musique]
elle est salt et les menaces à l'écrit
les bagarres la drogue et la peur c'est
ce à quoi sont confrontés de nombreux
résidents de cet immeuble ils ne peuvent
pas hausser le ton car ils risquent des
problèmes malgré les plaintes déposées
auprès de la police et des autorités
compétentes aux points de deal continue
de fonctionner selon certains les
appartements abandonnés sont à l'origine
du problème
on ne peut pas laisser les appartements
vides
le problème ce n'est pas tant
l'occupation ce sont les logements vides
selon l'institut national des
statistiques
l'espagne compte environ 3,4 millions de
biens immobiliers vide les derniers
chiffres datent de 2011 mais que cachent
ces chiffres la plupart des appartements
vides se trouve non pas dans les centres
administratifs des provinces mais dans
des zones rurales seul un et demi pour
cent de l'immobilier de barcelone est
vide malgré cela les experts et des
habitants demandent aux fonds
d'investissement et aux banques de
mettre sur le marché les surfaces
habitables inutilisés
[Musique]
le retentissement générés par le
problème des coûts passe fait le jeu des
sociétés de sécurité chacune de leurs
publicités jouent sur la peur et le flux
de publicité est incessant des sociétés
de sécurité sont les principaux
annonceurs de la radio espagnole et
l'opinion publique est elle si
préoccupés par cette situation
le nombre de procès contre des
squatteurs est passé de dix à quatorze
mille par an en espagne ces cinq
dernières années sur ses quatorze mille
selon le service social de barcelone 20%
des biens seulement appartiennent à des
particuliers
c'est-à-dire 2500 logements par an sur
25 millions de biens immobiliers au
total
les cas d'occupation de logement dans le
propriétaire possède de moins de 8 à 10
bien ne représentent qu'une toute petite
partie
au début raquel vivait dans
l'appartement de sa grand mère mais
comme cette dernière est morte raquel a
été contrainte de déménager
de temps avant l'un de ses voisins avait
été expulsé et son appartement était
restée vide pendant plusieurs mois alors
à qu'elle a brisé la grille de la
fenêtre est entré dans l'appartement et
ali est resté
aujourd'hui on criminalise beaucoup
l'occupation des logements mais n'en
avons pas le choix je ne suis pas une
criminelle je n'ai pas de casier
judiciaire je n'ai tout simplement pas
d'alternative
en entrant dans l'appartement raquel a
immédiatement apporté des matelas pour
donner l'impression qu'elle y vivait
depuis longtemps si une personne qui est
entré dans un appartement de cette
manière il passe plusieurs jours il est
presque impossible de l'expulser
immédiatement après le déménagement
raquel s'est empressé de mettre les
factures de services publics à son nom
une autre étape importante consiste à
discuter avec les voisins pour qu'ils ne
portent pas plainte
le parti je me sentais très mal
à nos trois jours j'étais sous le choc
je me sens encore malade rien que d'y
penser
ce n'est pas facile je ne souhaite à
personne de se retrouver dans une
situation pareille mais que faire je
dois le faire tant qu'à faire donc je
fais
pour raquel le sport est une bouffée
d'oxygène
toute sa vie est un combat perpétuel en
tant que mère célibataire elle est
obligée de surmonter seuls les
difficultés raquel en tant que victimes
de violence domestique est reconnu comme
handicapée elle perçoit une allocation
de 950 euros selon elle des centaines de
milliers de familles sont au bord du
gouffre en espagne
[Musique]
une fois j'ai été témoin d'une expulsion
j'ai dû me mettre sous la fenêtre et
jouer le psychologue pour qu'elles ne
sautent pas
[Musique]
cet homme s'appelle ep il a été expulsé
il ya moins d'un an et il n'a pas
d'autres logements il est au chômage sa
femme se rétablit des séquelles laissées
par le coronavirus la seule propriété
qui lui reste est en barre maintenant il
est fermé et pépé y entrepose ses
affaires
ce n'est pas une vie et je ne vois
aucune issue
j'ai travaillé pendant 30 ans et je
payais régulièrement mes impôts quand
j'ai eu des problèmes je n'ai droit à
aucune aide
quand il a perdu son travail bp a été
contraint de renoncer au statut
d'entrepreneur individuel il ne perçoit
des plus d'allocations dans une
situation si grave il a pensé à devenir
squatteurs mais ensuite il s'est rendu
compte que ça ne ferait que lui créer
encore plus de problèmes et paix a même
confié qu'à un moment donné il a voulu
mettre fin à ses jours
ça doit faire maintenant cette situation
me détruit
[Musique]
tout ce que je demande c'est un logement
social
[Musique]
la liste des gens confrontés à des
problèmes de logement en espagne
s'allonge sans cesse les expulsions la
spéculation le manque de logements
sociaux et l'occupation ne sont que
quelques pièces du puzzle que représente
la question du logement en espagne
on nous avait vendu l'idée que nous
vivrions milieu que nos parents mais ils
s'avèrent et la chute est dure que c'est
faux et ce sera encore plus faux avec le
temps
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ne sont toujours pas remises de la crise
hypothécaire
elle ne peut y avoir de solution de
facilité il n'y a pas de recette magique
personnes véritable volonté politique
toute initiative est vouée à l'échec
il ya des mesures à court terme sont
aussi fragiles que des bulles de savon
[Musique]